What was the word for what?
Kh.
And you remember how it was to pass?
Is it passar?
Pasar.
And this can also mean like to happen, to pass in the sense of to occur.
How do you say he passes?
Pasa.
Good.
And she passes.
Pasa.
And it passes.
Good.
And if you want to say what passes, meaning what happens, what's going on, what is happening.
Ah, I remembered it now.
I went through the whole process and I remember people saying, Gepaso.
Ah, this is the past.
We said that when you emphasize that O on the end, it's actually the version for he, she, it in the past, so que paso is what happened.
And we will look at this later.
But what what's happening?
What is happening?
Good.
So if you want to say I want to know what's going on, I want to know what's happening, I want to know what's passing.
Quiero saber qué pasa.
I want to know what's happening.
Good.
There's one more thing we need to know about the present, and it's gonna fill in happily a grey area for us, which you might be wondering already, how did we get tienne
He, she, it, you fumal, has or have, and then the other versions, tienen, tienes, from tener.
To want is ker.
What is I want?
Quiero.
So how does querer become quiero?
So there's something else we need to know about the present to understand this.
And then we can manage the present completely.
So what's happening is that when we have an E in the true form of the verb, like in tener to have, like in querer to want.
When we have an e inside of the verb, it's part of the root, not part of the ending, not that er, that doesn't count, but the e in ten and the e in ker of ker
When we stress it, when we emphasize it, it often splits, most of the time, it splits into an ie under the stress of that accent.
Under the stress when we say kerer, we have the accent on the end, we have the accent on the ending.
Then when we take off that air and we put o we would have quero, but when we stress down that e it splits and it becomes quiero.
The same for tener.
We would have ten for he has, but when we stress down on that e, it splits and it becomes tiene.
The same for come.
We have veneer, but when we say he comes, she comes, it comes, you fummel come, it would be bene, but it becomes bien.
Now it's not happening with Dengo, Bengo because we can say the N and the G kind of holds it up.
So this is probably why it got saved.
But otherwise it splits.
Now, this might seem quite of an abstract thing to get your head around, but what is very helpful is that we have these between words in English and Spanish
We can identify this between words in English and Spanish.
For example, we have a word that we use for time in English, but only in music.
Do you know what is this word?
A word we use for time, but only in music.
When you speak about the time, the rhythm of music, you talk about its.
Beat.
Not beat, but tempo.
Now, time in Spanish is tiempo.
You see the difference between tempo and tiempo, other than the Spanish pronunciation
Is that the E has split into IE.
So you can even see it between words in English and Spanish.
Concert in Spanish.
Consert in Spanish is trying to do the same thing
Concierto.
Good.
You stuck a note to make it sound more Spanish and you state that E.
Concierto.
November is Novembre.
So this will help us remember.
So this happens most of the time.
We already saw places it doesn't happen.
We saw very briefly the verb llegar, which was to arrive, and we said yego, I arrive.
We saw esperar, which was to wait or to hope
Espero.
It's not happening.
But most of the time it's gonna happen.
We saw it happening with tener, which became tiene, ki shiit you formul, tienen, they, are you plural?
Tienes you informul.
We saw it happening with venir, to come, bien, bienes, bienen.
Another verb that we see this with is pensar.
What do you think pensar means?
Thoughtful.
But it's a verb.
There's no verb to thought for, is there?
Ah.
Well to think.
Yes, that's it, to think.
It's very useful for us to group words into families.
So verb is a family.
So when you decide what type of word it is, then you narrow down the possible behaviors.
of that word and you manage to manage it much easier.
And making that very clearly that connection is really really helpful for you to think, pensar.
So if you say I think, how is it going to be
Pienso.
Good.
It would be pienso, but you stress down on that e and it splits into i and you get pienso.
How is uh he thinks or she thinks or it thinks or you formal.
This sounds like uh vowel harmony
I mean it sounds nice, PNC, because we have IE and then we want to put an E next to it because it matches.
But that's Turkish grammar.
You must know where you are with any verb, and to know where you are you must go back to the two form.
Then you are confident.
Pensar.
Not penser.
No, pensar.
So you must go back there and then you feel confident.
Otherwise the bass is gonna affect what vowel you want to put on.
Piensa.
You informal?
Piensas.
Good.
What do you think?
Que piensas.
Yeah, que piensas.
This is a useful verb as well actually because if you say I think to eat, it means I plan on eating.
You can say I think to eat.
That's simple.
I think to eat.
How would it sound?
Pienso comer.
Pienso comer
I think to eat later is I plan on eating later.
So how would you say I plan on eating later?
Pienso comer tarde.
That means I I I plan on eating late.
Which is fine, but later is more late and more is related to massive.
Mastarde.
Good.
Pienso comer más tarde.
I plan on eating later.
So you can use it like that as well.
We saw Banir also splits with the exception of Bengo.
He comes, she comes, you fume.
How would that be?
Biene.
They
Vienen.
You informal.
Vienes.
Good.
Do you remember how was when?
Quanto?
Quando?
When are you coming?
Cuanto vienes.
Cuando vienes.
Entender.
Entender means to understand.
You can use Compreender if you forget it, but Entender is better, it's more common.
But Comprehender is easier because it sounds like comprehend.
And also in Compreender the E doesn't split
I I understand this comprendo.
But with entender, it does clear.
So you can use comprender
But most common in Spanish is entender for understand.
And here the E does split.
So how would you say I understand?
How would you say he understands?
Entiente.
Good they
Entienden.
Perder.
Perder means to lose.
It's kind of related to perish.
There is a connection there or perishable food, you know, food that is uh that rots or real food per ver to lose.
I lose
Pierlo.
Good.
The process is per there.
Pierlo, maybe it splits.
Pierlo.
Good.
I lose it.
Lo pierdo.
Good.
I lose them.
Los pierdo.
Good.